on n'était pas très loin descente années
de combat et les anglais occupent est de
nouveau la moitié de la france
lorsqu'un jour de l'an 14 129 au mieux
appelle-moi la berchère le jeune fille
bah ouais il n'y en a qu'une
j'ai vu un hors jeu mais bien de me
bleux caisse quand est ce que l'on a
appris à parler de cette façon
ouais alors signer mon ami génial avec
le verglas touristique est bon ça va ça
va julie vient là et écoute moi
attentivement sous la barre et mal pour
les français
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et je pense qu'il
est donc temps que tu fasses ce que les
voix céleste avait ordonné à ta mère et
à sa grand-mère au bout et tesco fr
orale est impossible oui vous avez bien
lu
il faut qu'une jeune fille aille sauver
le royaume de france va te préparer mes
gars pas de calais c'est un ordre robot
aller
wozniak du snop est en crise vous avez
reconnu vous ressembler beaucoup tous
les deux à vos pairs et avoue grand-père
quand j'ai bien connu mais comment c'est
encore vous vous je vous croyez moi
votre père m'avait déjà posé cette
question et enfin la guerre est
commencée depuis 100 ans
vos grands pères avait signé un contrat
sans savoir quand les casimir russes
vivent plusieurs centaines d'années
c'est un scandale
populo monseigneur monseigneur c'est
trop tard et ce qui est trop tard parce
que vous m'avez demandé d'aller sauver
le royaume de france
j'ai demandé à mes voisins m'ont répondu
qu'ils avaient une certaine chaîne d'
art qu avaient battu les anglais à orio
c'est épouvantable nous allons êtes
jetés la même voie que nous gardions cas
les colons tourner et retourner en
angleterre
je n'aime pas le pouls des oui c'est
même bien ton traditionnel savoie et
puis le climat est humide
bon si vous voulez vous pouvez racheter
avec nous sur cette île o
c'est une excellente idée reçue mais
pour plus de six heures de simplicité
vous un sahara brin snob vous appellerez
à monsieur du snav
j'en ai très joli voilà et vous qu en
criques un tri et bien vous appellerez
campagne voilà tout simplement avec
comprendo à emile emile campagne ça vous
va aimer ou campagne emile campagne ou
hockey sans mot traître à écouter ne
perdez pas tort
allez vite porté la nouvelle à vos
navires de guerre
qu'ils repartent sans doute au comme ça
c'est extraordinaire ça et encore deux
minutes j'étais officier père présent
mais pour la fois acteur c'est la
destinée facteurs jeanne d'arc fût
brûlée à rouen mais charles 7 battu les
anglais qui ne gardent air quelques
années plus tard que la ville de calais
la guerre de cent ans et est enfin finie